why is Austria not in NATO?
after World War II, Austria,
like Germany,
was divided into 4 occupation zones,
even though it was not held responsible for the war
and was instead designated as the
first victim of pascism.
since the country was
occupied by both the Soviets and the West,
it was increasingly drawn into the Cold War.
neither side wanted to withdraw its
troops from the country
for fear that it would fall
under control of the other side.
in 1955, the then Austrian chancellor flew to Moscow
to negotiate the withdrawal of troops.
to make this happen,
Austria had to commit to
becoming a neutral and non aligned nation,
which meant that the country
could not join any military alliance
or allow foreign military bases on its soil.
however, this neutrality was often put to the test,
for example in 1999
when NATO used its airspace to bomb Serbia
even though Austria did not allow it to.
the country did not resist militarily,
only protesting politically.